micro casque et papier ces jeunes
d'elancourt sont prêts pour leurs
premiers enregistrements radio il
travaille pendant les vacances de
printemps pour créer leurs émissions ils
ont réalisé eux mêmes les reportages
voulez parler du championnat d'europe
presse passé le 10 juin à 21 heures il
faut deux mots là pour ça j'ai choisi de
parler de l'euro 2016 j'ai choisi de
parler de la vision des animaux bas
parce que c'est ce qui m'est venu à
l'idée c'est surtout bas j'aime bien les
animaux c'est passionnant comment
récolter des informations l'étrier
écrire un sujet autant d'exercices
abordé avec l'aide d'animateurs un
atelier proposé au centre de loisirs
pour faire découvrir les médias une
première pour la ville
donc vous avez fait un reportage sur les
mouches ont l'espoir pouvez-vous nous en
parler exactement on a passé on a posé
des questions à claude apprendre à
s'exprimer en public
l'aisance de la parole je pense que
c'est aussi un des objectifs de l'école
ça peut être aussi un objectif des sons
de loisirs
ça leur donne aussi un pouvoir
d'expression quelque part voilà donc ils
sont enchantés face à la motivation des
enfants la mairie prévoit déjà d'
organiser d'autres ateliers du même
genre l'émission sera disponible en
streaming sur le réseau de la ville